bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyse sur
pluie le principe de l'émission donner
du temps à nos experts pour donner du
sens à l'actualité voici le sommaire de
ce 7 décembre la guerre en Ukraine
a-t-elle changé de dimension après cette
frappe de drone loin à l'intérieur du
territoire russe ce sera le thème de
notre premier débat alors que Vladimir
Poutine a reconnu aujourd'hui un conflit
plus long que prévu
bien sûr c'est peut-être un long
processus mais de nouveautés sont
apparus c'est un résultat significatif
pour la Russie
le président russe qui a dû modérément
apprécié la une du magazine Time volody
mirzenski et l'esprit de l'Ukraine
personnalité de l'année on décrypte la
situation militaire et diplomatique dans
une minute et puis pour notre débat de
société retour sur la proposition du
député LFI aymeric Caron d'interdire la
corrida dans les villes taurines la
dérogation à la loi date des années 50
tradition culturelles et retombées
économiques pour les uns cruauté envers
les animaux symboles de notre rapport
aux vivants pour les autres on
confrontera les arguments de nos invités
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
la guerre sur le sol russe et la gêne
des Américains après ces frappes de
drones ukrainien Mathias Arès
à moins de 200 km de la frontière un
réservoir d'essence dans la ville russe
de kurksk a été la cible ce mardi d'un
bombardement la veille de Baza aérienne
située à plus de 600 km à l'intérieur
des terres russes étaient visées
ont été interceptés à la suite de la
chute et de l'explosion sur les bases
aériennes russes des débris des drones à
réaction la coque de deux avions a été
légèrement endommagée et 3 militaires
russes du service technique qui se
trouvaient sur place ont été
mortellement blessés
du côté des soutiens internationaux on
assure ne pas encourager cette nouvelle
stratégie ukrainienne le président l'a
dit très clairement il y a quelques
temps nous ne permettrons pas à
l'Ukraine d'organiser des frappes
au-delà de ses frontières nous
n'encourageons pas l'Ukraine à lancer
des frappes au-delà de ses frontières
pour l'heure l'origine des arbres reste
floues fin octobre une entreprise
ukrainienne d'armement communiquait sur
la mise au point d'une arme à longue
portée
la portée est de 1000 km le poids de
l'ogive est de 75 kg nous finalisons le
développement nous ne vous disons
pratiquement rien mais ce rien
fonctionne avec succès sur le champ de
bataille depuis ses frappes la riposte
ne sait pas fait attendre ce mercredi au
moins 6 civils ukrainiens ont été tués
dans une frappe russe près de Donetsk
voilà beaucoup d'actualités à débattre
avec mes invités autour de la situation
en Ukraine et en Russie avec Irina
mitrychin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
maître de conférence à l'INALCO
responsable de des études ukrainiennes
le général Dominique trinquant bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi ancien chef de la
mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU Julien Theron bonsoir bienvenue
enseignant conflit sécurité
international à Sciences Po et votre
livre Poutine la stratégie du désordre
jusqu'à la guerre avec Isabelle Mandrot
publié chez Tallandier Mathieu
croissanto évidemment et data et
politique à mes côtés comme chaque
semaine les on est quel jour
lundi et mercredi mais lundi vous étiez
à ma place c'est vous qui assuriez vous
aussi
c'était une très belle émission allez on
redevient évidemment sérieux est-ce que
c'est un est-ce que c'est frappe
ukrainienne sur le territoire russe
est-ce que ça change la donne voilà la
première question à laquelle on va
répondre ensemble Irina mitrychin
peut-être comment c'est reçu en Ukraine
j'ai l'impression que les autorités
ukrainiennes pour l'instant de
communiquent pas vraiment autour de ces
frappes quelles sont les infos qui
remontent de votre côté c'est une joie
contenue en quelque sorte on est
fanfaronne pas on sait très bien qui est
derrière on est heureux de voir que
l'industrie
ukrainienne l'armement parvient à faire
ce genre de merveilles ça redonne bien
évidemment de de la fierté aussi de la
confiance aux
Ukrainiens et donc aujourd'hui on
conjure sur les prochaines cibles je
préciserai quand même que les Ukrainiens
frappent que les infrastructures
militaires à savoir les les aéroports
d'où partaient les avions qui
bombardaient l'Ukraine ou bien les dépôt
pétroliers donc
c'est parfaitement justifié à au milieu
des Ukrainiens on peut pas mettre sur
une balance ces frappes avec les frappes
russes qui visent l'Ukraine qui vise des
civils qui visent les infrastructures
électriques etc etc
est-ce que c'est une surprise de la voie
effectivement le l'armée ou en
l'occurrence
l'industrie militaire ukrainienne
capable de viser de frapper aussi loin à
l'intérieur du territoire c'est pas une
surprise en Ukraine il y a une industrie
de l'armement importante à l'époque
soviétique il y a eu beaucoup de choses
qui étaient faites en Ukraine ça c'est
le premier point deuxièmement il y a une
capacité des ingénieurs à améliorer les
systèmes on se souvient du
du missile Neptune qui a coupé le mot
suivant qui était quelque chose qui
avait été arrangé par les par
l'usukrainiens donc ça veut dire quoi la
technologie d'origine qui peut être
américaine ou soviétique ou russe et il
a il la booste en quelque sorte c'est ça
d'abord la technologie
soviétique pour reprendre le terme russe
était faite en Ukraine une grande partie
donc à partir de là ils ont des
ingénieurs qui savent faire
ils ont la maîtrise donc donc c'est pas
tellement une surprise qui soit capable
de le faire
ce qui me frappe beaucoup dans ce qui
est arrivé là c'est la retenue des
Russes comme des Américains alors ça je
vais vous donner la parole là-dessus sur
l'aspect diplomatique et réaction des
années sur le plan technique moi je suis
pas surpris il y a plein de choses j'ai
participé à un briefing fait par l'armée
française il y a pas très longtemps et
avec ils ont sans surpris par des choses
incroyables ils ont mis en point un
système par exemple ou avec votre
téléphone portable votre iPhone vous
prenez un missile russe qui arrive vous
le filmez et automatiquement la défense
aérienne russe
ukrainienne pardon et prévenu et capable
d'intégrer les données qui permettent de
tirer sur le missile et ça c'est
participation de la population c'est pas
les militaires c'est tous les Ukrainiens
qu'on a le temps c'est-à-dire que si on
voit passer le missile à la frontière le
temps qu'il arrive à quelques centaines
de kilos c'est ça que j'essaie
pas à tous les coups mais je veux dire
si vous en avez quatre ou cinq qui le
font il y a bien un système qui va
permettre de se mettre en oeuvre et je
souligne que ça par exemple pour les
hormones françaises c'est une grande
leçon c'est à dire au lieu d'avoir des
systèmes très fermés est-ce qu'on a pas
intérêt à avoir des systèmes très
ouverts qui permettent en fait
d'accélérer le processus de lutte contre
ce type d'armes Julien Theron est-ce que
c'est quand même même si on va
effectivement voir que les réactions
diplomatiques voilà sont plutôt entre
guillemets calmes mais est-ce que c'est
quand même une étape supplémentaire ce
qui s'est passé avec ces frappes sur la
distance oui mais en réalité non parce
que il y a déjà eu des frappes sur le
sol russe notamment par des hélicoptères
à belgorodes des dépôts dont on ne
savait pas très bien si c'était des
drones des missiles ou des actes locaux
parfois on se demandait si c'était pas
les Russes ou des commandos Ukrainiens
donc en fait ça n'est certainement pas
la première fois que les Ukrainiens
frappent en territoire russe et alors
non seulement effectivement ce sont des
cibles militaires qui sont frappés mais
en plus il n'y a pas d'invasion des
Ukrainiens qui pourraient intégrer une
partie du enfin envahir une partie du
territoire russe ne le font pas donc
c'est juste effectivement une manière
d'empêcher les frappes contre l'Ukraine
donc ça n'est pas du tout effectivement
à mettre sur le même point pour rebondir
un peu sur ce que vous disiez
effectivement c'est un peu ce qu'on
appelle la défense totale en sciences
politiques mis au goût du jour 2.0
c'est-à-dire la manière dont la
population elle-même si on compare par
exemple avec un épisode qui s'appelait
la guerre d'hiver en Finlande quand
l'Union soviétique envahi la Finlande et
bien les finlandais faisaient déjà un
peu de ça donc là pardon on est on est à
quelle époque au milieu du du 20e siècle
et donc en fait les finlandais déjà tous
participer à l'effort de guerre un peu
comme les Ukrainiens le font aujourd'hui
parfois c'était en termes d'acquisition
du renseignement et en fait ça n'est pas
autre chose que de l'acquisition du
renseignement d'intérêt avec les outils
d'aujourd'hui avec les outils
d'aujourd'hui effectivement en temps
réel si vous avez comme vous le disiez 5
téléphones portables qui en temps réel
hop Connect immédiatement une
information on peut éventuellement
décrire une trajectoire pour répondre à
votre question oui selon le type de
missile il est possible d'avoir assez de
temps pour intégrer ces data et
déclencher une contre-mesure
effectivement oui ces techniquesment
possible mais c'est très intéressant de
voir ça et effectivement je veux le
préciser aussi on a toujours tendance à
dire alors l'URSS c'était la Russie et
donc les armes ukrainiennes qui étaient
en URSS viendrait de Russie parce que la
rue hassa c'est devenu Russie non non
l'Ukraine faisait partie de l'URSS et
c'est en continuité comme le Kazakhstan
ou d'autres pays de l'ancienne
URSS alors on voulait évoquer l'aspect
diplomatique on y vient tout de suite
avec on a entendu dans le sujet de
mathiasa une première fois le
porte-parole du ministère russe de la de
la défense je vous propose un autre
extrait de de sa réaction c'est c'est
presque aussi aller en biquer regardez
écoutez
le régime de Kiev afin de mettre hors
d'état de nuire des avions russes à long
rayon d'action à tenté de frapper avec
des drones de fabrication soviétique sur
la base aérienne militaire de diaguilevo
dans la région de Riazan et la base
aérienne Engels dans la région de
saratophe Dominique comment il faut
comprendre la communication russe après
ces frappes ukrainiennes donc il visait
je rappelle des des installations
militaires première réaction
ce ne sont pas les américains ils
auraient pu dire c'est des armes
américaines à mentir c'est pas la
première fois donc non tout de suite ce
sont des armes soviétiques d'ailleurs
ils le disent des armes soviétiques
ukrainiennes et donc c'est bien à
l'Ukraine qu'on a à faire donc on n'est
pas en guerre contre les Américains et
je rebondis tout de suite les Américains
disent la même chose on n'est pas en
guerre contre les les Russes puisque
c'est pas nous qui poussons à ce type là
donc les Américains comme les Russes
temporisent on n'est pas face à face
premier point deuxième point les
résultats sont mineurs il y a eu alors
on les a détruit mais attendez ça veut
dire qu'en escalade pas ça veut dire que
pour les Russes on minimise vous
comprenez on aurait pu attaquer contre
le seul sacré de la Russie etc etc
est-ce qu'elle a des non pas du tout on
laisse ça à un niveau mineur donc je
pense que les Russes qui sont bien
embêtés sur là-dessus au passage les
réseaux russes sont furieux en disant
mais attendez on n'est pas défendu
qu'est-ce qui se passe les bases où on a
nos avions stratégiques ou en plus des
images satellitaires sont publiées ou on
voit tous les avions alignés sur le
Tarma il y avait eu quelques jours
auparavant c'est ça des images de les
Russes disent mais attendez qu'est-ce
qui se passe on n'est pas défendu vous
mettez même pas en alerte de vos
systèmes et voilà ce qui arrive donc je
pense que les Russes sont très ennuyés
par ces frappes là et simplement dans la
communication veulent minimiser ce type
d'attaque pour ne pas d'abord en venimer
la situation et que la population
ressentent ne ressentent pas ça trop
durement alors on a entendu Irina
mitrychin la réaction américaine
effectivement là aussi assez loprofile
pas de volonté d'escalade mais en creux
on a parfois en entendant le la réaction
américaine on se dit est-ce que est-ce
que l'Ukraine a le droit de frapper sur
le sol russe vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il y avait un peu cette cette
pardon d'employer ce terme cette petite
musique dans dans l'air aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je pense
que cette déclaration elle était liée au
type d'armes que les Américains les
vrais au fait que ces armes étaient
censé n'est pas aller jusqu'au
territoire russe
maintenant on a eu aussi des réactions
comme celle des responsable allemand qui
a dit que l'Ukraine a parfaitement le
droit de se défendre à titre 51 de de la
Charte de l'ONU donc en fait le personne
de conteste le fait que les Ukrainiens
ont le droit d'utiliser leur propre
armes qui n'ont pas été livrés par
l'Occident pour mener leur propre
opérations militaires oui parce qu'il y
avait cette idée d'armes de de défense
alors plutôt que d'arme d'attaque je
suis pas assez spécialiste j'en pourrais
peut-être pas les les bons termes Julien
Theron mais bon et c'est ce que ce qu'on
ressent dans la réaction de officielle
américaine il y a quand même il y a
quand même une gêne des Américains ou
une crainte de voir leurs armes utiliser
un peu au-delà de ce qui était prévu
est-ce que est-ce que vous l'analysez
comme ça oui oui depuis le début les
américains craignent ça mais il y a un
accord avec Yves qui est de dire vous
n'utiliserez pas les armes américaines
pour frapper le sol russe point à la
ligne
le cas a été discuté sur la Crimée il y
a pas eu nécessairement de problèmes sur
la Crimée puisque c'est un territoire
reconnu international comme un
territoire ukrainien donc ça ne pose pas
nécessairement de problèmes là on est
dans un autre cas parce que c'est un
territoire reconnu internationalement
comme russe effectivement mais ce ne
sont pas des armes américaines donc il y
a en fait il n'y a techniquement pas de
question et sur la légalité de cette
action l'Ukraine il faut le redire la
Russie n'a pas le droit d'attaquer son
voisin parce qu'il n'y a eu aucune
raison d'ailleurs ils n'ont même pas
déclaré la guerre parce que
officiellement ça n'est pas une guerre
en revanche effectivement on regarde de
la Charte des Nations Unies l'Ukraine a
le droit légal de se défendre contre la
Russie alors dans cette partie de notre
débat sur le les conséquences on va dire
diplomatiques je demande à Quentin
Calmet de nous rejoindre bonsoir Quentin
avec une intervention très intéressante
aujourd'hui le général de l'armée de
l'herbe Bruno Clermont qui était reçu au
Sénat et qui a évoqué évidemment ses
attaques de drone oui tout à fait les
sénateurs lui ont demandé est-ce que une
ligne rouge a été franchie comment
comprendre effectivement la prudence des
Américains qui ont redit à ne pas
encourager telle frappe ces attaques
tout simplement change-t-elle la donne
écoutez effectivement l'analyse de Bruno
clairement il est clair que que la ligne
rouge des
Occidentaux c'est nous dirons vous donne
de l'armement vous avez pas le droit de
frapper la Russie vous avez même pas le
droit de frapper la Crimée les quelques
rares frappes qu'il y a eu sur la Crimée
ont été faites avec des armements
Ukrainiens soviétique en tout cas pas
des armements occidentaux donc cette
limite elle est mis à émise parce que la
priorité est la seule priorité des
Occidentaux des Américains mais je pense
également et c'est dit comme ça du
président Macron et de l'OTAN c'est de
ne pas aller jusqu'à le conforta son
direct entre l'OTAN et la Russie parce
que la Russie assimilé peut-être
nucléaire
autre question quelle sera la réplique
de la réussite dans les prochains jours
dans les prochaines semaines sans doute
une nouvelle pluie de bons meurtrières
sur le territoire ukrainien selon
l'expert militaire alors peut-on aller
jusqu'à l'utilisation d'une arme
nucléaire Bruno Clermont et également
revenu sur ce point et si vous les
rassurant écouter donc effectivement la
frappe de la Russie je pense qu'il va y
avoir des représailles très sérieuses de
la part des Russes avec encore des
missiles qui vont tomber sur l'Ukraine
en grande quantité la question du seuil
nucléaire moi je l'aborde tout de suite
parce qu'elles étaient plus ou moins
évoquées moi j'y crois pas j'y crois pas
parce qu'en fait imaginons imaginons que
la Russie tire une arme nucléaire de
faible puissance sur l'Ukraine le monde
s'arrête
et le général a également dressé un
bilan au
286ème jour de guerre voilà un bilan
très sévère pour l'armée russe dès le
départ avec l'invasion manqué au début
du conflit qualifié de désastre par ce
général pendant cette audition l'armée
russe est minée par la violence la
corruption et le manque d'entraînement a
également dit Bruno Clermont l'une des
principales surprises depuis février a
dit ce gradé c'est la faiblesse de son
aviation à la Russie écoutez donc le
général ce matin une dernière fois une
dernière extrait de la commission de la
défense c'est énorme oui c'est vraiment
une surprise incroyable pourquoi cette
aviation hyper puissante a été si mal
utilisée c'est parce qu'il savent pas
faire ils savent comment il faut faire
ils savent ce qu'il faut faire ils
recopie copier coller la doctrine
américaine mais s'entraîne pas ils ont
pas les outils ils ont pas les
mécaniques ils ont pas les chefs pour ça
ils ont pas les structures de les CAO
que la mécanique de la planification de
la boucle j'observe je détecte je tire
une savent pas faire ça il s'entraîne
pas ils sont mauvais voilà je vois plus
simple ils sont mauvais donc alors que
les Ukrainiens ils sont pas nombreux
mais sont bons donc vous voyez il faut
il compense leur sous-effectif et leur
sous-équipement par une excellente
gestion de leurs moyens voilà ce
militaire qui a dit que tout se
déroulait de la guerre côté russe lui
lui rappelait des affrontements du 20e
siècle plutôt qu'une guerre du 21e
siècle merci beaucoup Quentin sont des
discussions qu'on a déjà eu sur ce
plateau je vous propose on va ouvrir
maintenant sur l'état de l'armée russe
et sur son déploiement Vladimir Poutine
qui a créé prix pardon la parole
aujourd'hui
sur ce déploiement 150 000 réservistes
mobilisés en Ukraine voilà ce que dit le
président russe j'y arrive pardon sur
300000 de nos combattants mobilisés nos
hommes nos défenseurs de la patrie 150
000 sont en formation et l'autre moitié
des soldats se trouve dans la zone
d'opération
77000 se trouve directement dans des
unités de combat tandis que le reste se
trouve en deuxième ou troisième ligne
agissant en tant que trouble de défense
ou suivant une formation complémentaire
dans la zone de l'opération alors si je
comprends bien généralement ce sont les
réservistes la mobilisation qui avait
été annoncée en septembre on est dans ce
cadre-là c'est pas une nouvelle
mobilisation en tout cas pas à l'instant
T non pas l'instant T alors il y a un
grand flou comme vous le savez sur la
mobilisation puisque le chiffre de 30000
a été annoncé alors que l'article 7 du
décret
annonce des chiffres beaucoup plus
importants donc aujourd'hui on est un
peu dans le foie supérieur
bon on sait pas trop on annoncé un
million bon donc c'est mais aujourd'hui
il y a un autre sujet c'est que
normalement les réservistes devaient
passer trois mois en formation avant
d'être envoyé au combat on voit bien que
c'est pas le cas puisqu'il y en a qui
sont déjà au combat et on sait qu'il y
en a qui sont morts dans les quelques
jours après la mobilisation
le problème des Russes aujourd'hui c'est
de réorganiser leur force alors ça a été
l'objet du décrochage de Carson ils sont
partis de Carson pour réorganiser les
forces et ils sont en train de se
concentrer dans la région du Dombas et
dans la région du Dombas c'est là qu'il
y a le plus de combat actuellement mais
là dedans vous avez donc les forces qui
étaient sur la droite du Nieppe qui sont
récupérés pour faire ça plus les
réservistes qui comptent des trous et
ceux qui sont en formation qui
pourraient former des unités pour venir
alors avec l'équipement c'était une
grande question puisque il y a quand
même beaucoup d'équipements prétend
qu'il y a pas loin de la moitié des
chars qui ont été détruits donc avec
beaucoup d'équipements en plus qui
viennent d'où de stocks probablement
assez ancien et donc les Russes
aujourd'hui ont beaucoup de mal à se
réorganiser pour faire quoi pour
s'installer en défensive donc si vous
voulez quand le président Poutine
annonce qu'il a gagné des terrains et
tout oui il devrait annoncer qu'il est
en train d'en perdre progressivement
alors le seul endroit effectivement
effectivement je sais pas si on en
parlera après ces backmouth c'est un cas
particulier on en parlera tout à l'heure
parce que c'est un cas particulier c'est
Wagner c'est pas vraiment l'armée russe
donc voilà la Russie a du mal à se
réorganiser comme ça l'Ukraine en
revanche qui était sur l'offensif qui a
gagné à Carson qui a gagné un quartier
aujourd'hui elle se prépare pour une
nouvelle contre-attaque qui a été
annoncé d'ailleurs par le président
Zelinski on ne sait pas où aujourd'hui
forcément sinon les plans seraient
éventés mais il y a un problème de
mouvement il y a un problème de météo
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
disent l'hiver n'est pas un handicap
pour les actions offensives au contraire
ça ne gèle pas les actions militaires
les soldats ont froid naturellement
des uns et des autres plateaux voilà
mais surtout ça permet la mobilité les
blindés quand le soleil peuvent bouger
en revanche la boue de l'automne voilà
en revanche
soldats qui sont à étrangers pour eux
c'est beaucoup plus dur donc voilà Irina
de Mitry est-ce qu'on sait combien
d'hommes et de femmes parce qu'il y a
évidemment des femmes aussi qui sont
mobilisés et dans l'armée ukrainienne ça
représente combien de personnes et et
vous avez pas cette info ou à quel point
la population
ukrainienne puisque cette guerre dure on
va on va atteindre les 10 mois de de
conflit ce mobilise militairement aussi
est-ce que je me fais bien comprendre
c'est-à-dire des gens qui étaient pas
forcément des militaires de carrière pas
forcément des réservistes et qui
finalement sont rentrés dans le conflit
par volonté ou à la demande des
autorités donc il y a pas eu de
conscription générale à l'Ukraine donc
il y a eu beaucoup de de volontaires
donc qui sont engagés il y a d'ailleurs
une pétition qui a été lancée pour
permettre aux gens qui ont servi pendant
un an de pouvoir être relevé de de
pouvoir souffler le ministre la défense
a répondu que ce n'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que ça marche parce que faire
partir un million de des personnes qui
sont formées suppose pouvoir former les
gens qui viendraient les remplacer ce
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas évident
mais
ce qui est clair c'est que les
Ukrainiens sont dans la lancée et sont
conscients ce n'est pas le moment de
relâcher et qu'au contraire il faut
engranger les victoires maintenant que
la situation se pote sachant que la
Russie pourrait profiter très
certainement d'une trêve pour se
reconstituer et reprendre au printemps
oui donc la trêve profiterait plus à
l'armée russe qu'à l'armée ukrainienne
Julien Theron commence pardon là aussi
c'est vraiment des questions de base
mais mais pour rebondir sur ce que vient
de dire mitrychin sur la mobilisation
des Ukrainiens il y a quoi il y a des
rotations entre ceux qui sont au front
et ceux qui sont à l'arrière comment
comment une armée s'organise sur le long
terme
c'est obligatoire qu'il y a des
rotations peuvent pas rester comme ça au
combat pendant tout le temps et puis on
en parle assez peu mais les Ukrainiens
subissent des pertes aussi même si
[Musique]
beaucoup de réservistes chaque année qui
se sont qui se sont formés en Ukraine
c'est un territoire en guerre donc il y
a eu des gens qui sont à guéris grandes
parties de la population masculine dans
tout on pourrait dire que les Russes a
été aussi un petit peu le cas parce que
la Russie a fait tourner les troupes
énormément en Syrie par exemple donc il
y a eu 60000 soldats qui ont été
aguerris en Syrie mais on regarde des
pertes qu'ils ont effectivement 60 000
du coup ça fait pas tant que ça je
voudrais préciser sur cette histoire de
mobilisation en Russie que il y a eu la
mobilisation
partielle mais il y a eu aussi une
mobilisation en général aussi il y a un
appel militaire qui est le 1er avril et
le 1er octobre ça c'est tous les ans
quoi tous les ans d'accord donc il faut
additionner ces troupes là plus le fait
qu'on est en train de parler d'une
nouvelle phase de mobilisation qui
devrait intervenir tout en ne sachant
pas si la précédente était déjà terminée
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est qu'en fait il y a probablement un
processus assez continu de recrutement
et de mobilisation les chiffres qui sont
donnés par le ministère de la défense
sont des chiffres les plus officiels des
officiels 300 000 c'était l'objectif ils
en ont pile 300 000
c'est comme s'il y avait un chiffre et
une époque obligé de les prendre pour
argent comptant absolument tous les
éléments d'information qui nous
proviennent de Russie que ce soit des
déserteurs des services de renseignement
ou quoi nous démontre que c'est l'exact
inverse les unités ne sont pas complètes
il est difficile de prendre des gens
enfin je veux dire bon je vous donne
mais peut-être que vous pourrez intégrer
à votre réponse c'est l'une des phrases
du jour cette phrase on l'a vu en titre
on vous la repropose pas une niveau mais
c'est Vladimir Poutine qui reconnaît qui
dit la guerre est un long processus et
donc est-ce que c'est un aveu d'échec en
creux oui il faut rappeler qu'il pensait
gagner en trois jours à peu près enfin
une semaine donc évidemment ça lui
paraît long
le processus d'incorporation et de
mobilisation fait que par exemple la
compréhension du mois d'octobre a été
repoussée au mois de novembre parce
qu'en fait il n'arrivait pas à engranger
en même temps les mobiliser et les
incorporer du côté ukrainien pour pour
voir côté il y a beaucoup de formations
qui sont faites aux États-Unis en
Grande-Bretagne en Europe il y a une
mission de l'Union européenne qui a été
lancée pour former et qui a démarré très
très vite d'ailleurs on est l'Europe est
surprenante en ce moment déjà des
processus qui prennent des mois là se
règle en quelques jours et en quelques
jours on a mis une mission avec un
commandement en Allemagne un
commandement en Pologne et il y avait
une mission sur le déminage qui était
qui était préparé en France donc l'armée
ukrainienne continue à se former a été
équipé et à se préparer en Russie elle
fait ça toute seule la Russie et donc
elle a quelques difficultés d'autant que
il faut rappeler que l'armée russe a été
réformée en 2008 et qui a jamais eu de
processus de mobilisation depuis 2008
c'est à dire qu'ils sont en train de
découvrir en marchant comment est-ce
qu'on fait ou est-ce qu'on met les gens
d'où les images qu'on a vu de de gens
qui étaient mobilisés qui ont pas
d'armes ou de l'équipement qui le fichu
parce que les centres n'ont pas été
testées la mobilisation eux-mêmes une
partie de leur équipement parce que la
mobilisation c'est quelque chose qui se
prépare régulièrement à l'époque où en
France on avait ça on avait des
exercices tous les ans de mobilisation
là il y en a plus donc ils font ça
pendant la guerre ce qui est un peu
compliqué alors je réponds reviennent
maintenant sur les frappes russes en
Ukraine qui continue évidemment avec
d'abord cette cette visite et cette
réaction du haut-commissaire des Nations
Unies au droit de l'homme volcan turc il
visite les ruines d'un bâtiment qui a
été détruit à isium 56 villes ils ont
été tués on l'écoute
nous sommes ici à isum au milieu d'une
autre scène de destruction insensée
vous voyez derrière moi un immeuble de
plusieurs étages avec des signes de vie
du passé
lorsque les personnes qui vivaient dans
ce bâtiment ont essayé de trouver un
abri
[Musique]
le bâtiment s'est effondré et nous avons
trouvé plus de 50 corps et nous les
avons documentés
évidemment les frappes russes continuent
sur l'Ukraine aujourd'hui on a appris la
mort de six civils cinq autres blessés
dans une ville proche de denietz que
Irina mitrychin
c'est le président zenensky d'ailleurs
qui a annoncé ce bilan dans cette ville
proche de doniak quel retour vous avez
de ces villes bombardées on voit on voit
ces images on va parler
d'une autre ville dans un instant vous
l'avez cité tout à l'heure c'est la vie
de backmouth on dit c'est le Verdun du
gambas on va bien bien faire la
différence mais quel retour vous avez
comment les habitants tiennent dans ces
villes bombardées qui sont quasiment
détruites ils sont partis ailleurs ils
sont comment ça se passe il y a des gens
qui restent là c'est la frappe sur
coraco
c'est malheureusement une litanie qui
est triste etannique se répète tous les
jours pratiquement les gens sont
résignés donc ceux qui voulaient partir
sont partis ce qui tient à rester
malheureusement confronté à ce risque là
et donc chaque frappe ne fait que
remonter en quelque sorte la colère des
Ukrainiens et leur envie de tenir je me
souviens la dernière fois que vous êtes
venu sur ce plateau vous aviez évoqué un
mouvement d'une partie de la population
vers des villes plus rurales voilà
est-ce que ce mouvement c'est massifié
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup du craignent
qui ont dû quitter les villes parce que
l'alimentation électrique est coupée que
c'est peut-être je le mets plein de
guillemets plus facile de de survivre
dans une vie quotidienne dans un dans un
village de campagne ce mouvement
concerne plutôt les agglomérations dont
les infrastructures électriques ont été
touchées et lorsque vous habitez dans
une tour au 13e étage vous n'avez pas
d'ascenseur vous avez l'électricité deux
heures par jour etc pas de chauffage
donc effectivement ceux qui peuvent sont
invités partir vers vers les villages
tout simplement parce qu'on peut se
chauffer au bois on peut trouver
d'autres d'autres solutions mais il y a
aussi des gens qui continuent à vivre
dans ces dans ces immeubles qui
s'organisent pour pour aller travailler
dans un espace de coworking ou dans les
ou dans les cafés donc donc aujourd'hui
les les coupures sont annoncées sont
réglementées donc quand ça ne correspond
pas tout à fait à ce qui a été annoncé
c'est c'est soit matière à une déception
soit à des blagues en disant à une belle
surprise je me suis préparé à travailler
dans le noir et en fait la lumière était
là j'ai même pu voir un film au terminer
à cuisiner un plat donc il y a cette
résistance qui est prête à tenir en tout
cas aujourd'hui au début de l'hiver
début décembre les gens ne sont
absolument pas prêtes à abandonner alors
dans une vidéo qui a été postée sur les
les réseaux sociaux les médias sociaux
volody merzelinski a rendu hommage aux
soldats à l'occasion de la Journée des
forces armées du pays alors ils visitait
la ville de slow viands qu'on est à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de backmoon
donc ce principal champ de bataille de
la région écoute le président ukrainien
tout de suite
[Musique]
aujourd'hui traditionnellement je me
retrouve sur la ligne de front avec nos
soldats
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans le
don-basse la zone de guerre c'est
agrandi la lutte est plus dure le prix
est plus élevé mais ce qui reste
inchangé c'est votre courage votre
endurance votre volonté est donc notre
liberté votre indomptabilité et donc
notre indépendance
2050 je lis de plus en plus à propos de
backmouth Le Verdun du don-basse
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette ville
dans cette région oui alors c'est la
guerre privée de Monsieur prigogi le
patron de Wagner donc ce sont des
milices en quelque sorte des mercenaires
des mercenaires dont il faut rappeler
que c'est les mercenaires qui viennent
de partout qui viennent en particulier
des prisons et comme vous le savez
aujourd'hui
Wagner est présent en Afrique aussi et
je déjeunais avec des Africains qui
m'expliquaient que ils recrutait dans
des prisons africaines également pour
les envoyer en Ukraine donc ce sont
c'est un mercenaire ce sont des
mercenaires et Monsieur Prigogine veut
remporter une victoire et donc il envoie
au casse-pipe à l'abattoir des gens qui
sont absolument pas formés
on prétend même qu'il y a des soldats
qui sont à usage unique c'est le terme
qui est employé pour essayer d'obtenir
une victoire de façon à pouvoir démontré
qu'il est meilleur que l'armée russe
parce que Monsieur Prigogine veut avoir
une place particulière dans
l'environnement du Kremlin et en Russie
et donc mais ça fait des semaines quand
je dis des semaines c'est je crois qu'il
y a plus de deux mois qui sont en train
de essayer d'attaquer donc c'est
l'endroit où se concentre les moyens et
quand on dit effectivement c'est le
Verdun c'est parce que quand on voit les
images il y a je sais pas combien d'obus
au mètre carré qui ont été envoyés donc
c'est c'est de l'artillerie qui a
beaucoup tiré mais il progresse vraiment
très très lentement Irina mitrychin pour
vous c'est c'est une autre ville martyr
il y en a eu tellement d'autres
précédemment ou est-ce que il y a le
sentiment que c'est encore pire ce qui
se passe à bakhout aujourd'hui on a vu
les images d'une ville pratiquement à
rasée et les villes autour également
donc bien sûr c'est numériquement ce
n'est pas Mario Paul mais elle a même le
même chemin si vous voulez c'est répéter
et on est conscient de la victoire va de
l'import symbolique de cette ville
symbole qui aura aussi un impact sur sur
les troupes sur la la suite de la de la
guerre mais malheureusement on est on
était pratiquement prêts à voir c'est
cette ville détruite est-ce que c'est un
verrou stratégique cette cette ville ou
pas forcément oui relativement il y en a
d'autres
mais c'est intéressant de voir voir ce
qui se passe parce qu'en fait c'est
typique de des doctrines soviétiques
anciennes notamment de d'un penseur
militaire qui s'appelle listerson
c'est-à-dire que c'est à la fois de la
tricion c'est typiquement ce qui se
faisait pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale de détruire juste avec des
bombardements sur une guerre de position
et puis et puis une gare de mouvement en
réalité les Soviétiques faisaient
beaucoup ça c'est à dire un énorme
barrage d'artillerie pour créer des
grandes percettes blindées qui pénétrait
ce que les Russes essayent de faire
depuis et c'est très intéressant de voir
ça qu'ils aient ils essaient de vous
faire ça pardon à baroute parce que ça
veut dire qu'en fait il ne s'adapte pas
à la condition on voit que les
Ukrainiens non seulement en termes
d'armement mais aussi de de ta on se
souviendra par exemple vous savez de ces
motos électriques avec deux hommes
dessus
approchés vraiment en silence et puis
tirer un temps qu'avec un système
anti-tank et puis de vivre de partir
mais on passe ça par exemple c'est
typique de l'adaptation aux guerres
contemporaines alors que ce qu'ils
essayent de faire à baroute ça
correspond à ce qu'ils essaient de faire
depuis des mois et qui ne fonctionne pas
vieux schéma en fait c'est une guerre du
20e siècle
j'ai pensé à ça quand vous quand vous
disiez ça tout à l'heure cette référence
ils n'ont pas modernisé leur tactique de
guerre conventionnelle et pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il ne devait pas
faire une guerre conventionnelle en
Ukraine il devait par impressionner mais
ce qui est quand même étonnant ça fait
10 mois que que cette et ce constat les
uns et les autres vous nous l'avez fait
assez vite donc il y a une incapacité de
l'armée russe à se réinventer en quelque
sorte oui elle applique des schémas en
fait et on connaissait ça avant les
années 90 on apprenait par coeur les
schémas de l'armée soviétique avec le
bataillon de tête le renfort
l'artillerie etc là dans dans ce qui
s'est passé effectivement l'armée qui
était là elle était faite pour
impressionner le gouvernement
ukrainien devait tomber à Kiev quand ça
n'a pas fonctionné il faut le
reconnaître parce qu'il faut pas avoir
que des côtés négatifs les Russes ont
été capables de faire une manœuvre
opérative une bascule opérative
gigantesque à partir de Kiev et de la
Biélorussie de tout basculer dans le nom
de base et ça militairement c'est
quelque chose de compliqué de même que
la retraite de Carson ils ont réussi à
la faire et donc c'est des choses
compliquées mais dans l'attaque dans
l'application des schémas d'attaque ce
sont que des schémas des bombardements
des bombardements et puis ils avancent
progressivement et abaquemouth c'est
même pas d'ailleurs pour faire des
percées blindés parce que ils n'en ont
quasiment pas c'est de l'infanterie et
qui progresse très très mal alors si je
peux sur Wagner originellement Wagner
c'était censé être une force d'élite
constituée essentiellement de forces
spéciales d'anciens du renseignement
militaire et en fait justement regarde
l'appétit de Monsieur Prigogine ils sont
tellement
faut le rappeler au mois de février et
dont cette offensive dont un des
objectifs vous l'avez rappelé était
président de le destituer le plus
rapidement possible celui sur lequel des
rumeurs de contrats ont été lancées
aussi notamment par auprès de cette
milice enfin de ces mercenaires Wagner
c'est une sacrée revanche pour un clown
je dis clown parce que c'était sa
profession enfin il était acteur comique
et il s'était attiré au moment de son
élection d'ailleurs beaucoup de
moqueries ou de critiques de la part de
l'Occident où on voyait en lui une
avatar du néo populisme troupier c'est
j'ose dire un peu dans la lignée on se
demandait est-ce que ça serait un bébé
grido est-ce que ça serait voilà mais il
nous a surpris mais voilà il a surpris
son monde il a même surpris le monde
entier il a troqué ses costumes ajustés
pour des treillis et des t-shirts kakis
tout aussi ajustés engranger des
victoires symboliques dès le début de
l'offensive et avant des succès
militaires dis-moi après les victoires
symboliques ça a été d'abord en assurant
le maintien d'un état ukrainien et d'une
présidence contre vents et marées c'est
quand même pas évident et il a symbolisé
ça tout de suite en remportant ensuite
très vite la bataille de la
communication de façon moderne
percutante à grand renfort de réseaux
sociaux ensuite en convainquant
l'Occident que ce jouet sur le sol
ukrainien une guerre qui l'est
concernait tous les tous les pays de
l'Occident en s'imposant comme un
partenaire digne de confiance avec
auquel on pouvait livrer des armes et
puis un partenaire auquel sur lequel on
pouvait compter alors il s'est montré
pressant vis-à-vis de l'OTAN vis-à-vis
de l'Union européenne plutôt constant
sur ses positions influents gens de sa
communication sur tous les espaces
possibles ont la même vue j'allais dire
au congrès du Medef cette année on l'a
vu il y a deux semaines avec Sean Penn
il a fait feu de tout bois si j'ose dire
en s'exprimant partout où il pouvait
s'exprimer alors bien sûr il a fini par
aussi par emmagascer plus d'un je pense
à Emmanuel Macron avec lequel le courant
n'est jamais passé mais aussi c'est
générosalies américains notamment quand
il y a eu ce missile qui s'est crashé
sur le sol polonais ou là on verra les
conséquences de ce tir enfin de ces
attaques de drones sur le sur le sol
russe mais l'histoire retiendra quand
même que c'est lui voler c'est un ski
qui a fait vaciller Poutine il l'a pas
fait tomber très branler mais enfin il a
il a
résisté après 25 ans de règne quand même
Poutine mais c'est qui ce qu'il a fait
c'est lui voilà ce qui alors ce titre ne
lui fera bien sûr pas gagner la guerre
alors personnalité de Live exactement
j'espère que ça lui fera pas perdre la
tête on peut l'espérer en tout cas parce
que le risque existe quand on se
souvient vous souvenez qui était le
dernier personnalité de l'année par Time
et le Must il a un peu perdu la tête et
ben voilà
réflexion j'ai une question peut-être
presque un peu provocatrice et Irina
mitrychin concernant volody merzelinski
je vous l'explique moi j'ai souvent
depuis le début de ce conflit en tête le
parallèle ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais
avec la première année de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et avec le rôle de
Churchill en Grande-Bretagne mais la
démocratie anglaise fonctionnait il y
avait une opposition à Churchill qui
pouvait s'exprimer même s'il y avait ce
sentiment de de d'appartenance et et la
reconnaissance de son rôle est-ce qu'il
y a une opposition à zelinsky une
opposition politique vous voyez ce que
je veux dire est-ce qu'il y a des
critiques de temps en qui s'exprime ou
alors plus du tout
les critiques existent maintenant il y a
une sorte d'union sacrée où toutes les
forces se sont dit que d'abord les
l'essentiel maintenant c'est la guerre
et on fera les comptes après il y aura
des règlements de comptes inévitablement
il y a beaucoup de questions qui sont
déjà posées ici et là ça ne remonte pas
jusqu'à contester son son pouvoir mais
il y aura forcément un retour pour
l'instant cette opposition essaie de ne
pas tirer dans les pas dans quelque
sorte de de de garder l'objectif
principal qui est de gagner la guerre et
de savoir que l'ennemi n'est pas
accueillir mais plutôt à Moscou après je
pense qu'il y aura des forces de
position anciennes mais surtout je pense
qu'il faudrait voir il y aura des
figures qui vont émerger du côté des
militaires ça c'est intéressant
très intéressant le parallèle avec
Churchill le très beau film les heures
sombres qui montrent la guerre
parlementaire au moment où la France est
envah et la guerre qu'il gagne pour
continuer la guerre puisque la question
était là l'opposition je rappelle que le
Parti conservateur lui voulait pactiser
avec les Allemands et au passage Hitler
ne voulait pas attaquer l'Angleterre
donc tout ça c'était assez compliqué
mais il y a un autre phénomène qui
m'intéresse là c'est le rôle de l'Allier
qui est totalement soutenu par les
alliés mais qui doit pas se mettre
complètement dans les mains des alliés
alors sur l'affaire des frappes dans la
profondeur en Russie je pense que là il
réussit son coup les Américains ont beau
dire bon c'est fait c'est fait en
revanche il avait raté le coup de du
missile qui était tombé en Pologne tout
le monde dans sa communication dans sa
communication tout le monde a été très
en admettre que voilà et tout le monde a
été très gentil avec lui il a pas
enfoncé d'ailleurs parce qu'au début il
a dit je suis sûr c'est un truc russe
etc etc
le temps disait le contraire les
Polonais en particulier qui étaient sur
le terrain il y a une équipe
ukrainienne qui est allée enquêter on
n'a jamais eu les résultats de l'enquête
au passage on n'a jamais ce qui ne veut
pas dire d'un nid dans un sens et je
suis d'accord mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que son opposition c'est noyé là
parce que parce que parce que c'était le
point de vue des alliés qui était le
plus important mais dans ce qu'il vient
de faire des tirs dans la profondeur il
veut marquer c'est moi qui veut
intimider les Russes qui veut marquer au
Russe quels sont leurs limites c'est
presque pardon nous interrompre est-ce
que c'est aussi un message à Vladimir
Poutine
bien sûr c'est un peu frapper Moscou oui
alors bon comme le comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure
les missiles ou les drones
Ukrainiens ne frappent que des cils
militaires donc
Moscou je vois pas l'affaire mais c'est
intéressant moi je trouve ce rapport en
Allier parce que vous faites des
rapports historiques moi ça me rappelle
lorsque la première armée française
remontait le Rhône et aller sur le Rhin
et les Américains disaient maintenant la
guerre s'arrête là pour vous parce que
l'Allemagne vous vous avez été vaincu
vous y allez pas et le général Delattre
d'accord bien sûr avec le général de
Gaulle a dit moi je franchis le rein et
il est allé jusqu'à toute garde et
d'ailleurs les militaires américains
l'ont aidé en fait comme lorsque la
deuxième DB est venue à Paris faut
rappeler que ça a été un accord plus
militaire que politique pour venir et
donc c'est très intéressant de voir ces
rapports avec les alliés qui doivent
rester eux-mêmes quand même parce que
c'est leur liberté c'est leur combat
alors vous nous d'aider et vous avez
droit de dire des tas en particulier à
faire du missile bon on s'écrase on
parle pas mais quand même on a aussi
notre droit à la parole parce que c'est
notre guerre est-ce que je posais la
question et je vais sur le message à
Vladimir Poutine parce que Vladimir
Poutine et tu cible militaire c'est
peut-être absurde ce que je dis mais moi
je pense à ça quand je vois vos limites
en déplacement tout près du front
comment ces deux chefs d'État sont
protégés d'une certaine façon alors
disons le premier Bouclier c'est le
secret et vladire Poutine
a mis en place un secret absolu même de
sa présence on ne sait jamais où il est
il est je doute fort que même le
renseignement ukrainien ou les Forces
Spéciales soient capables de le
localiser et de toucher mais d'ailleurs
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit un
objectif et je crois que ce serait
peut-être très contre-productif pour le
crâne elle-même
et rien ne démontre qui suivent ce
chemin là non non je crois qu'il faut
comprendre que il y a deux positions qui
sont très différentes si on est à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur du pays et
que de la part du président Zelinski
dont le pays est menacé de destruction
existentielle au sens strict du terme
puisque c'est ce qui est dit par le
pouvoir russe les Ukrainiens n'existent
pas on doit exterminer ce qui disent
qu'ils sont Ukrainiens donc de ce point
de vue là je crois que quand on en est
là et qu'on voit ce qui se passe
notamment les bombardements sur les
civils oui tout incitation arrêtait le
combat y compris de détruire les bases
d'où proviennent les aéronefs qui fera
plus crâne c'est assez compréhensible
alors nous on voit ça de l'autre côté de
l'Europe en faisant oui mais enfin quand
même il frappe la Russie c'est presque
la même chose non c'est pas du tout la
même chose ils sont menacés d'extinction
en Ukraine il faut bien comprendre ça et
ils essayent de faire en sorte que ça
s'arrête en fait la négociation ça finit
toujours par la négociation ça n'est pas
la question Perse je vais lire les
Américains parlent russe les Français
parlent les Ukrainiens par le russe il y
a eu des rames de négociation depuis le
début donc il n'est pas la question de
savoir si on discute ou pas si on
négocie ou pas ce sont des espèces de
poncifs qu'on répète pour pour trouver
une alternative au combat cinétique mais
la réalité c'est que la négociation est
permanente et qu'il faut trouver des
incitations pour pousser les Russes à
arrêter le combat c'est ça et à rendre
les territoires qui ont qui se sont
attribués de l'État souverain ukrainien
et les incitations oui ça peut passer
par ça merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Julien
Théron je rappelle le titre de votre
livre coécrit avec Isabelle mondreau
Poutine la stratégie du désordre jusqu'à
la guerre il est publié aux éditions
taland